son cada vez más cuentos los ataques
rusos sobre zonas civiles con este
último bombardeo que destruyó un
hospital infantil en mariupol estamos
ignorando deliberadamente la normativa
humanitaria y los civiles están siendo
usados tal vez como estrategia de guerra
si es obvio que es así porque la
conversión de ginebra y los distintos
agregados que ha tenido establece la
obligatoriedad de respetar por ejemplo
al personal sanitario
respetar las zonas que están vinculadas
con la actividad sanitaria y respetar
por ejemplo a los enfermos que están
recluidos en este tipo de
establecimientos y entonces cuando se
obvia esa esa disposición
se extravían a estar cometiendo incluso
crímenes de guerra y aquí hay que
aclarar el asunto que no es solamente
que se pueda alegar que se hizo por
error porque si se hizo deliberadamente
pues obviamente obviamente es un acto
atroz pero si se hace por se cometen
este tipo de actos por error igual e
implica una responsabilidad porque se
tiene que tener el suficiente cuidado
para poder llevar a un ataque de tal
manera que no se viole lo allí
establecido y eso implica responsable y
lo responsable en algún momento cuando
llegue el momento tendrán que rendir
cuentas por ello mencionábamos hace un
momento el avance de las tropas rusas
que se mueven rápidamente por el sur
mariupol sigue a duras penas en pie lo
mismo mykolaiv y odessa que gana rusia
con el control del mar negro y con el a
vice am avasallamiento del estado
ucraniano
bueno el mar negro tiene una importancia
estratégica
determinante porque un imperio sin
poderío naval no es imperio por
definición y esa es una zona además de
que es rica para realizar actividades
como por ejemplo el turismo etcétera
además es una zona que es perfecta por
ejemplo para el uso militar en tanto
sitio para establecimiento de flota y
sitio que conecta a mediterráneo es
decir que permite una salida
eficaz para a rusia para el mediterráneo
y eso es lo que está pretendiendo de una
u otra forma la federación rusa porque
es volver a las fronteras que tenía
anteriormente la extinta unión soviética
y precisamente a través por ejemplo de
un país como ucrania se tiene esa
conexión esa salida al mar negro y las
posibilidades de utilizar lo repito en
este sentido fundamentalmente es militar